Guten Tag. Ja, guten Abend. Ich bin heute die zuständige Ärztin für Sie und möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch
durchführen. Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, können Sie mir das sagen.
Sind Sie damit anverstanden? Natürlich. Hauptsache jemand guckt nach mir. Ja.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Name und Ihr Nachname, bitte? Ja, mein Vorname ist Tim. Familienname ist Schröder.
Können Sie das bitte buchstudieren? Mein Vorname ist ganz einfach, T-I-M. Kürzer geht eigentlich nicht.
Und Schröder, S-C-H-R-Ö, also U, umlaut, D-E-R, Schröder. Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Schröder?
Ich bin 59 Jahre. Wann sind Sie geboren? Ich bin am 12.3.67 geworden.
Wie viel wiegen Sie und wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin 1,80 und ich wiege jetzt noch 70 Kilo.
Was führt Sie zu uns, Herr Schröder? Also ich habe solche komischen Bauchschmerzen,
die mir eigentlich immer mehr werden und mit meiner Verdauung stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Und ich merke, dass ich in letzter Zeit richtig schlapp werde. Ich kriege nicht mehr gut Luft und ich fühle mich schlapp.
Ich schwitze und nachts schlafe ich ganz schlecht ein. Ich habe überhaupt keinen Appetit mehr.
Ich fühle mich einfach schwach und krank. Mein Hausarzt hat gesagt, ich soll das mal abklären lassen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Bauchschmerzen? Die Bauchschmerzen, das ist ungefähr seit 5 Wochen, kann man sagen.
Ich habe dann immer gedacht, das geht auch wieder weg. Aber es ist immer noch wieder, dass es heftig ist.
Wo genau haben Sie diese Bauchschmerzen?
Man kann das in der Mitte, um den Bauchnabel herum sagen.
Um den Bauchnabel. Sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich angefangen?
Ja, am Anfang denkt man, klar, ich habe vielleicht irgendwas verkehrtes gegessen.
Das geht eigentlich schon eine Weile, dass ich immer mal wieder Durchfall habe.
Und dann kann ich wieder drei Tage oder so überhaupt nicht auf die Toilette gehen.
Dann habe ich das Gefühl, jetzt ist aber eigentlich Zeit, dass mal wieder was kommt.
Dann habe ich so ganz festen Stuhl. Das ist immer so im Wechsel. Das kenne ich von früher eigentlich gar nicht.
Am Wechsel haben Sie Durchfall und Verstopfung.
Ich muss den Bauchschmerzen noch ein bisschen fragen. Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Von 1 bis 10, wenn wir eine Skala haben, wenn 1 bis 10 sehr leichte und 10 sehr starke Schmerzen bedeuten.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Ich kann das ja aushaltlich sagen.
Aber das Krampf zwischendurch so. Dann wird es halt schlechter.
Ich würde sagen, über die Hälfte sind wir schon vielleicht so bei 6.
Und sind Sie dauerhaft oder sind Sie wieder wächelnd?
Das sind eigentlich so Wellen.
Ganz schlimm ist es, wenn ich festen Stuhlgang machen muss oder auch wenn ich Durchfall habe.
Dann habe ich das Gefühl, dann sind die Bauchschmerzen mit einem mal ganz tüchtig.
Und nach dem Stuhlgang ist es besser?
Ja, wenn es dann raus ist, habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich für einen Moment wieder Erleichterung habe.
Aber dann geht es irgendwann eben wieder los.
Haben Sie einen Auslöser bemerkt?
Ich kann das nicht an irgendwas festmachen.
Ich habe dann natürlich versucht, ob es an einem Essen liegt, dass ich dann helles Brot gegessen habe.
Oder dann habe ich meine Weide den Zucker weggelassen oder nur ganz wenig gegessen.
Aber ich habe den Eindruck, das hat alles überhaupt keine Bedeutung gehabt.
Und eine Verstärkung oder Linderung Faktor haben Sie nicht bemerkt?
Oder auch nicht?
Ja, also wie gesagt, nach der Toilette fühle ich mich dann so ein bisschen erleichtert.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, wenn ich dann so im Bett liege und eine bestimmte Position einnehme,
dass ich dann denke, jetzt kann ich es gerade ganz gut aushalten.
Wenn Sie sich vielleicht nicht so bewegen, ist es vielleicht besser?
Ja, ich denke, ich liege dann so ein bisschen zusammengekrumpt im Bett.
Und dann habe ich das Gefühl, dann geht es ganz gut.
Verstärkung und Linderung Faktor haben Sie nicht bemerkt?
Nur nach dem Stuhl, haben Sie gesagt.
Was für Schmerzen sind Sie?
Sind Sie dumpfstechend?
Nee, stechend sind sie nicht.
Also eher dumpf, würde ich sagen.
Dumpfwellenförmige?
Ja, so kann man sagen.
Ja, so krammartig einfach.
Und seit fünf Wochen haben Sie gesagt?
Ja, so ungefähr.
Und die anderen Beschwerden?
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie schwitzen, dass Sie keinen Appetit haben.
Sind die anderen Beschwerden auch so?
Ja, das ist eigentlich so.
Ja, ich habe wahrscheinlich vorher schon auch nicht gut gegessen.
Das kommt ja so schleichend irgendwie, dass man dann sagt,
oh nee, heute habe ich keine Lust, groß zu essen oder so.
Und dann hat einen das nicht so gelockt oder so.
Aber das kann ja auch was, was ich an anderen Sachen liege.
Deswegen habe ich das gar nicht so registriert.
Aber ich habe eben festgestellt, weil ich auch so wenig Appetit hatte,
dass ich auch ordentlich abgenommen habe.
Abgenommen, ja.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber?
Also ich habe mich nicht gemessen,
aber tatsächlich habe ich zwischendurch so,
dass ich so schwitze.
Es ist natürlich jetzt auch draußen warm und beim Wetter,
ja, da kann man ja auch schon mal ins Schwitzen kommen.
Aber ich denke, das ist schon ein bisschen mehr.
Das kannte ich eigentlich früher nicht so.
Haben Sie Schüttelfrost bemerkt?
Schüttelfrost habe ich tatsächlich nicht gehabt, nee.
Nachtschweiß?
Nee, nachts.
Also das ist jetzt nicht besonders stark,
dass ich in der Nacht schwitze.
Es ist so eigentlich zwischendurch immer mal wieder,
dass ich schwitze, aber nachts nicht besonders.
Okay, nicht besonders.
Der Appetit ist nicht gut, haben Sie gesagt, seit fünf Wochen.
Und Sie haben abgenommen, wie viel Kilo haben Sie abgenommen?
Ja, ich wiege jetzt nur noch 70 Kilo.
Ich habe immer so 73 wenigstens gewogen.
Also drei Kilo sind weniger.
In fünf Wochen, oder?
Ja, sechs Wochen vielleicht, sieben Wochen, keine Ahnung.
Also ich wiege mich ja nicht ständig.
Und dass ich so keinen großen Appetit habe,
das merke ich eigentlich schon eine ganze Weile.
Und waren Sie inübel und haben Sie erbrochen?
Nee, das musste ich nicht.
Wie ist es mit dem Wasserlassen?
Haben Sie Probleme?
Ja Gott sei Dank nicht, nee.
Das Stuhl ist verwechselnd,
wechselnd, haben Sie gesagt.
Ja, und ich habe eigentlich schon seit langer Zeit Probleme.
Ja, das ist zwar so, entfernt hat es mit dem Stuhlgang was zu tun,
dass ich so ausgeprägte Hämorrhiden habe.
Aber das ist auch schon mehrfach operativ angegangen worden.
Da hat man so Bandligaturen gemacht.
Und das ist immer mal wieder erforderlich, ja.
Dann haben Sie auch Beschwerden vielleicht wegen Hämorrhiden?
Ja, das habe ich schon länger.
Das habe ich schon seit Jahren eigentlich ein bisschen.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Durchfall haben?
Wie viele Mal müssen Sie durchfallen?
Wenn ich Durchfall habe,
dann ist das vielleicht zwei, drei Mal hintereinander.
Also wie viele Mal haben Sie Durchfall?
Nochmal.
Irgendwie hängt unser Bild gerade.
Ich habe sie nicht mehr online.
Wo war ich denn?
Der Durchfall haben Sie gesagt, drei bis zwei Mal täglich, wenn Sie Durchfall haben?
Ja, genau.
Dann ist der Stuhlgang sehr weich, sehr flüssig.
Aber ich muss dann nicht ständig zur Toilette gehen.
Dann ist es wieder gut.
Okay, gab es Blut im Stuhl?
Ja, durch diese Hämorrhiden gab es immer mal ein bisschen Blut.
Das kenne ich ja schon.
Okay, ein bisschen Blut wegen Hämorrhiden.
War es Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Ich kann schlecht einschlafen.
Ich komme schlecht zur Ruhe.
Wenn ich dann aber erstmal schlafe, geht es eigentlich.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Einschlafprobleme?
Vielleicht seit einem halben Jahr.
Und natürlich auch, je nachdem bei der Arbeit, wenn man mal Stress hat.
Dann schläft man auch ein bisschen unruhiger ein.
Dann ist man in Gedanken noch da beschäftigt.
Das kenne ich eigentlich schon länger.
Okay, jetzt haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Oder ist es Ihnen etwas eingefallen, außer diese Beschwerden?
Das lange war auch füllig, würde ich sagen.
Hautfarbeveränderungen, Fällungen in den Beinen oder irgendwo in dem Körper nicht, oder?
Nee, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Also, ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, ich kriege nicht so gut Luft.
Da habe ich dann auch das Gefühl, dass ich ein bisschen mehr pumpen muss.
Dass das Herz ein bisschen schneller schlägt.
Wann bekommen Sie die schlechte Luft?
Können Sie mir das kurz erzählen?
Bei Belastung oder hängt das von ohne Belastung auf?
Ja, also bei Belastung, ich fühle mich so schwach, dass ich jetzt im Augenblick zum Beispiel nicht gut eine Treppe hoch kann, wenn ich noch eine schwere Tasche tragen muss.
Da muss ich langsam tun.
Da bin ich früher schnell hochgelaufen und jetzt muss ich halt irgendwie ein bisschen langsam machen.
Ist das auch seit fünf Wochen?
Ja, so ungefähr würde ich sagen.
Die Schwäche.
Haben Sie Schmerzen in den anderen Körperbereichen?
Ja, das hat damit glaube ich nichts zu tun.
Ich habe schon seit langer Zeit ein bisschen Kniebeschwerden.
Ja, in beiden Knien.
Insbesondere bei Belastung, wenn ich viel unterwegs bin, da habe ich wohl ein bisschen Arthrose oder so etwas drin.
Aber das ist jetzt noch nicht so, dass mich das stark behindert.
Und da nehme ich halt hin und wieder mal eine Schmerztablette.
Also das denke ich, ich denke deshalb nicht mit die Schmerzen.
Nee, das ist sicherlich unabhängig davon.
Was für Vorerkrankungen haben Sie außer der Arthrose? Erkrankungen?
Ja, also ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Das hat man vor ungefähr zehn Jahren festgestellt.
Und da nehme ich jetzt morgens eine Tablette Walzertan.
Und ja, wo ich auch manchmal so ein bisschen Probleme habe, dass ich so sauer aufstoßen muss, dass ich so...
Ja, deswegen muss ich auch beim Essen manchmal so ein bisschen aufpassen, dass ich abends nicht zu viel esse oder dass ich nicht zu scharf esse oder...
Haben Sie vielleicht alle.
Dann nehme ich aber Omeprazole ein, wenn ich die Beschwerden habe.
Bei Bedarf nehmen Sie Omeprazole. Wissen Sie die Dosierung von Walzertan und Omeprazole?
Oh nee, was da drauf steht, kann ich Ihnen echt nicht sagen.
Das sind ja auch die einzigen Medikamente, die ich nehme, außer dem Ibuprofen.
Und ja, das liegt da irgendwo auf dem Tisch, aber ich lese tatsächlich nicht, was da drauf steht.
Okay, ich verstehe. Das können wir noch klären.
Haben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, also sonst, da war ich eigentlich ja immer ziemlich fit, würde ich sagen.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Na ja, gut, diese kleine Eingriffe wegen der Hämorrhiden halt.
Wegen Hämorrhiden, okay.
Und wegen dieser Beschwerden waren Sie beim Hausarzt oder irgendwo?
Ja, ich bin bei dem mal gewesen in letzter Zeit und dann hat er gesagt,
ja, das kommt mir schon komisch vor, Sie sollten sich doch mal in der Klinik vorstellen bei Gelegenheit.
Und jetzt sind halt endlich Ferien und jetzt habe ich Zeit, mich darum zu kümmern und deswegen bin ich jetzt gekommen.
Okay, haben Sie Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten?
Ja, ich kann tatsächlich Paracetamol nicht vertragen.
Deswegen muss ich also bei Schmerzen was anderes nehmen.
Und da kriege ich ja so einen ganz fiesen, juckenden Ausschlag und das kann ich nicht nehmen.
Aber das ist das Einzige, von dem ich weiß.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, also ich arbeite als Lehrer und da war das ja ganz klar wichtig,
dass man in der Corona-Zeit, dass man sich halt komplett impfen lässt.
Und auch die Grippeimpfung mache ich jetzt schon viele Jahre immer mit.
Und alles, was so auf dem Zettel ist, mache ich eigentlich ganz konsequent.
Sehr gut. Hatten Sie eine Reise in der letzten Zeit, in den letzten sechs Monaten besonders?
Ja, also einmal waren wir an der Nordsee und einmal haben wir Freunde in Österreich besucht.
Aber jetzt nichts Exotisches, würde ich sagen.
Okay. Gibt es einige in Ihrem Umfeld, die ähnliche Beschwerden haben?
Nein, nein, nein. Also Sie meinen, dass wir irgendwas Verkehrtes gegessen haben oder so?
Nee, nee, also ich bin der Einzige bei uns in der Familie.
Okay. Und ja, noch ein paar Fragen, Herr Schröder. Rauchen Sie?
Ja. Wie viel und was rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche Zigaretten und ja, das muss ich zugeben, ich rauche ziemlich viel.
Also zwei Päckchen am Tag sind es schon, ja.
Oh, das ist schon sehr viel. Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Na, das hat mir die neuen Arbeit angehört, so seit 15 Jahren ungefähr.
Okay. Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also Alkohol. Also ich trinke gerne mal ein Glas Wein und jetzt, wenn es zu warm ist, trinke ich auch gerne mal eine Flasche Bier zum Abendessen oder so.
Aber das hält sich sehr im Grenzen.
Nicht jeden Tag, oder?
Nein, nicht jeden Tag.
Manchmal gelegentlich, okay.
Jetzt muss ich eine Routinefrage stellen. Nehmen Sie das bitte nicht persönlich. Nehmen Sie Drogen ein?
Nee, nee, das kann ich mir als Lehrerin wirklich überhaupt nicht lassen.
Ja, Lehrer, ja, genau. Denke ich auch so.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind schon groß, die sind aus dem Haus. Aber wir haben zwei Kinder, ja.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, zum Glück sind sie gesund, ja.
Ja, sehr gut. Und Sie leben mit Ihrer Ehefrau?
Mit meiner Ehefrau zusammen, genau.
Sehr gut. Und für Ihren Beruf sind Sie Lehrer?
Haben Sie auch vielleicht Stress in der Arbeit?
Ja, das gibt eben immer so Phasen, wo es ganz turbulent zugeht. Und ja, wenn man zum Schuljahr das Beginn eine neue Klasse hat oder wenn jetzt so die Zeugniskonferenzen sind,
da ist natürlich immer viel los.
Okay, ich denke, wir sind jetzt fertig mit unseren Fragen. Herr Schröder, möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich möchte jetzt natürlich schon gerne wissen, was man tun kann und was dahinter steckt und ob das irgendwas ist, wo man sich Sorben machen muss.
Also, ja, das ist, ich werde jetzt einfach gerne los, das Problem.
Ja, ja, ich verstehe Sie. Wir machen alles, was wir können. Wir sind hier ein Team, wir arbeiten zusammen.
Ich mache jetzt erstmal eine körperliche Untersuchung. Ich nehme Blut ab und vielleicht ein Stuhlkultur wäre gut. Und die Ideal- und Körperparameter überprüfe ich.
Und dann schauen wir, wie es weitergeht, okay?
Okay, gut.
Herr Schröder, darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Ist Ihnen ein Schleim in einem Stuhl aufgefallen?
Schleim?
Ja, ein schleimiges Stuhl.
Also nur wenn ich Durchfall habe, dann habe ich so ein bisschen schleimiges Stuhl, ja.
Danke.
Darf ich?
Ja, natürlich.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Meine Eltern, ja, die sind zwar schon hoch betagt, aber sie leben beide noch, ja.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie bedeutende Krankheiten, zum Beispiel Krebs, Polytochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht. Ich habe mal was mitbekommen, dass man bei meinem Vater so Darmpolypen festgestellt hat.
Bei so einer Darmspiegelung. Und die hat man dann entfernt, aber damit war es eigentlich auch gut.
Eigentlich sind die ziemlich fit.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Geschwister habe ich nicht, nein.
Okay, danke schön.
Heilstunden haben Sie Ohrgeräusche?
Ohrgeräusche?
Ja, genau.
Nee, die habe ich Gott sei Dank nicht, nein.
Sind Sie nicht schwindelig?
Mir ist nicht schwindelig, nee.
Aber Sie sind müde?
Müde und schlapp bin ich, ja.
Schlapp und müde, okay.
Gibt es noch Fragen?
Guten Tag, Frau Oberärztin. Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten. Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen, wenn Sie Zeit haben.
Ja, natürlich gerne. Wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Tim Schröder ist 59 Jahre alt, wiegt 70 Kilogramm und ist 1,80 Meter schwer.
Groß.
1,80 groß.
Er stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit fünf Wochen bestehenden, plötzlich aufgetretenen Dumpfe Abdominalgie bewertet mit 6 von 10 vor.
Aber ich habe plötzlich oder langsam, das habe ich glaube ich gefragt vorhin, sind Sie plötzlich oder langsamer betreten? Ich habe es plötzlich gesagt, aber die Schmerzen.
Und begleitend leidet er an Inapetens, Diarrhea und Observation, wechselnde Diarrhea und Observation. Er fühlt sich sehr schwach.
Und die Schmerzen sind um den Nabel angefangen.
Wie nennt man das?
Im Paraumdikalbereich.
Aber Sie sind jetzt nicht nur im Paraumdikal, Sie sind diffus. Er hat diffus Abdominalgie. Begleitend fühlt er sich schwach.
Er hat keinen Fieber, aber ein fiebliges Gefühl. So Schweißausbrüche hatte er glaube ich.
Schilderfreus wurde verneint. Besonders nach Schweiß hat er nicht, aber Schweißausbrüche hat er.
Er leidet an Inapetens. Er hat abgenommen 3 kg in 5 Wochen. Emesis und Nausee habe er nicht.
Er hat auch keine Nixionprobleme. Er leidet an Hemorrhoiden. Das wurde früher behandelt. Aber ab und zu hat er wegen dem Hemorrhoiden auch Beschwerden.
Der Stuhl war flüssig. Wenn er Diere hat, ist der Diere flüssig und manchmal blutig wegen Hemorrhoiden.
Er leidet an Insomnie. In Form von Einschlagproblemen. Ab und zu seit 6 Monaten.
Als Vorerkrankungen leidet er an Arthrose, wie gesagt Hemorrhoiden und seit 10 Jahren an arterielle Hypertonie.
Als Medikamente nehme er einmal morgens Wasser, Tann und bei Bedarf Omeprazolein Allergien.
Er hat eine Palästhetamol Allergie, die sich mit Exanthem äußert. Als Voroperation hatte er nur eine Behandlung wegen dem Hemorrhoiden.
Sonst hatte er keine Operation gehabt. Der Impfstatus war vollständig. Er sei ein Lehrer vom Beruf. Er ist ein Lehrer vom Beruf.
Er rauche zwei Packungen Zigaretten täglich. Seit 15 Jahren trinkt er ein Glas Wein und manchmal wächst eine Flasche Bier. Gelegentlich Drogenkonsumworte verneint.
Er sei verheiratet, habe zwei gesunde Kinder. Die Reise an dem Nese war unauffällig. Er war im Nordsee, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das mit dem Beschwerden zu tun hat.
Er hatte keine Tropenreise. Ich habe noch die Bauchschmerzen gefragt, ob er einen Auslöser bemerkt hat.
Er hat keinen Auslöser bemerkt, aber nach dem Stuhl ging es besser. Die Schmerzen haben sich gelindert. Wenn er sich hingelegt hat, ist es auch besser geworden.
Und sonst hat er nichts bemerkt. Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Vermutung? Vermutung? Ich bin nicht so sicher, aber kann es ein Reisdarmzentrum sein?
Oder was noch? Gastroenteritis, aber das hat er seit fünf Wochen. Das wäre ein bisschen lang.
Vielleicht eine Unvertretigkeit habe ich gefragt. Das könnte auch eine Unvertretigkeit sein. Vielleicht eine Intoleranzkrankung, zum Beispiel Laktosintoleranz.
Aber er hat gesagt, er hat nichts bemerkt, dass es mit den Nahrungszutun hat. Seit fünf Wochen. Was könnte es noch sein?
Kronen, vielleicht entzündliche Darmerkrankungen sollten wir überprüfen. Und was noch? Worst case? Im schlimmsten Fall?
Das ist eine Kolonkranzenung. Muss man gucken. Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Erst muss ich die Vitalparameter überprüfen, körperliche Untersuchungen. Worauf achten Sie besonders?
Ob es Hautfarbeveränderungen gibt. Was würden Sie erwarten? Hepatomegalis, Splenomegalis, Lymphalempatien.
Also wegen Tumor. Das Schlimmste sollten wir ausschließen. Und eine digitale, digitale Untersuchung ist wichtig, wenn wir an Kolonkranzenung denken.
Digitale und digitale Untersuchungen. Lymphoanopathie, Hautfarbeveränderung. Das erwarte ich nicht. Was muss ich noch achten?
Vielleicht Lymphknoten? Ja, Lymphknoten, Lymphoanopathie. Ach so, ich habe die akustisch nicht verstanden. Der größte Lymphknoten.
Gut, was machen Sie weiter diagnostisch? Also was mache ich weiter? Blut muss ich abnehmen. Gut, was lassen Sie bestimmen?
Also die Entzündungsparameter. Blutbilds. Leberwerte, Dierenwerte. Was erwarten Sie beim Blutbild?
Lekositose vielleicht. Und was vielleicht noch? Was vielleicht noch? Was kann es noch sein? Angel. Wie bitte?
Passientat, Hemorrhoiden. Ah, Hemorrhoiden. Anämie. Anämie könnte es sein. Hätte sich auch bei der Hautfarbe vielleicht in Blässe gezeigt.
Ja, genau. Dann sollten wir einen Hemokultest vielleicht auch überprüfen. Hemokultest für chronische entzündliche Darmkrankungen.
Das war ein Test, aber ich kann mich nicht erinnern für diese. Ah, okay, da gibt es irgendwie Indikatoren.
Und digitale Untersuchungen habe ich ja gesagt. Und ja, Kolonoskopie. Vielleicht müssen wir durchführen, für den Pollen sehr auszuschließen.
Genau. Was noch? Und noch Bauch- und Ultraschallloch. Ja, genau. Da kann man vielleicht auch was sehen.
Gut, ja. Dann würde ich doch sagen, gehen Sie an die Untersuchung, informieren Sie mich bitte über die Befunde.
Und dann schauen wir uns den Patienten halt nachher zusammen an und gucken, was dann am ehesten wir als Diagnose haben,
dass wir dann auch wissen, wie wir mit den Patienten umgehen, dass wir therapeutisch mit denen machen können. Gut, ja, wunderbar.
Okay. Ja, also, Frau Dr. Dari, es ist ein Jammer, dass Sie nicht übermorgen Ihre Prüfung machen können.
Ich bin so überrascht, wie jemand, der nicht mal hier in Deutschland lebt und eigentlich ja keine Chance hat, mit anderen Deutsch zu sprechen, wieder so gut Deutsch spricht.
Das ist echt super. Sie sprechen ausgezeichnet und sie machen wirklich so gut wie keine Fehler, wirklich.
Und wir haben eine sehr schöne Anamnese gemacht, eigentlich sehr konsequent. Was mir auch gefallen hat, dass Sie so auf das eingegangen sind,
was der Patient Ihnen schon so an Vorinformationen gegeben hat. Die halten sich ja nicht immer alle an Ihren Fragebogen, sondern die erzählen ja auch im Vorfeld schon irgendwas, ja.
Und also wirklich sehr gut, sehr gut das aufgefangen. Eine Winzigkeit halt im Fragenbereich, dass Sie die Familienanamnese vergessen haben.
Ja, das habe ich jetzt vergessen. Ja, ja.
Ja, na ja, aber ich würde mal sagen nichts dramatisches. Und sonst haben Sie wirklich konsequent alles auch in einer logischen Reihenfolge abgefragt.
Und die haben Sie eigentlich auch sehr schön eingehalten. Sie haben einen guten Einleitungssatz gehabt für das Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Das also wirklich, der war vollständig und ja, war aber auch nicht überladen. Hat mir gut gefallen. Ja.
Und dann haben Sie eigentlich auch die ganze Diagnostik schön beschrieben. Ja, was glaube ich nicht rausgekommen ist, dass der Patient gesagt hat, es ist gelegentlich luftnötig.
Das haben Sie glaube ich im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch nicht erwähnt. Und was Sie auch nicht erwähnt haben, Sie haben zwar gesagt, dass der an Medikamenten, weil er tauschen würde,
Sie haben zwar gesagt, dass der an Medikamenten, weil Satan und Omeprazole war, bedarf, nimmt. Aber Sie haben im Vorfeld nicht gesagt, dass der so einen Reflex hat.
So einen Reflexbeschwerden. Das haben Sie halt nicht erwähnt. Das wäre sonst, würde sich das nicht so automatisch ergeben, dass er eben das Zeug braucht.
Was ist jetzt die Diagnose? Also die Diagnose. Was ist jetzt die Diagnose für diesen Teil?
Also dieser Fall ist als Colonkarzinom angegeben. Und differenzial diagnostisch ist hier das Reisdarm-Syndrom drin. Das ist der Kron drin.
Und das hat mal irgendjemand gesagt, fand ich aber eine spannende Idee. Hängt natürlich ein bisschen damit zusammen, dass ich viele Jahre in der Gefäßchirurgie gearbeitet habe.
Das ist der Gedanke, dass der eine Mesentereal-Embolie hätte. Also das glaubt man ja immer nicht, dass auch die Mesentereal-Aterien, wenn da irgendwelche Probleme sind,
dass dann die ganze Verdauung nicht mehr funktioniert. Und für mich ist immer so ein bisschen überraschend, dass die Bauchschmerzen eigentlich nicht im Unterbauch sind,
sondern so para- und belikal sind. Das hätte ich jetzt so bei Magen gedacht. Aber das scheint so zu sein, dass das eben auch typisch ist für das Colonkarzinom.
Warum auch immer. Ja gut, das Cola nimmt natürlich einen großen Teil ein. Ist schon klar. Und ja, wie auch immer.
Ja, und Sie haben dann auch bei den ganzen diagnostischen Verfahren, haben Sie genau die Sachen gesagt, die wichtig sind.
Sie haben die Stuhlkultur angegeben. Sie haben den Hämokoltest angegeben. Sie haben die Choloskopie angegeben. Ja, also das wollen wir mehr.
Und natürlich direkt die Hade-Tast-Untersuchung. Einmal wegen der Hämorrhiden, einmal wegen des Colonkarzinoms. Perfekt.
Ich glaube, mehr kann man nicht erwarten. Ich gerne schon seit langem. Ja, aber mit gutem Erfolg.
Aber ich bin auch in Stuttgart geboren. Das war Ihr großer Vorhaben. Deswegen sprechen Sie so gut.
Ja, deswegen vielleicht. Aber für FSB habe ich mich noch vorbereitet. Speziell vorbereitet. Ja, speziell vorbereitet.
Ja, aber es ist wirklich sagenhaft. Sie haben so eine ganz unbeschwerte Art Deutsch zu sprechen.
Und das fällt halt auf, weil Sie es fast als Muttersprache mit gelernt haben. Das ist natürlich unheimlich hilfreich.
Hoffentlich kann ich kommen nach Deutschland und dann zeigen, was Sie können.
Hoffentlich, bald. Vielen Dank.
Ja, herzlichen Dank für die schöne Demonstration heute Abend.